the dune saga which is set approximately
20,000 years in our future revolves
around the evolution of mankind both
physically and mentally over the course
of several thousands of years book 1
introduces the character Paul Atreides
the result of a breeding program which
had been going on for many generations
orchestrated by the Bene Gesserit
sisterhood a secretive and powerful
order of women who manipulated the
inhabitants of the Imperium through use
of their many mysterious skills Paul is
a central character of the early novels
in dune mankind has spread out to more
than 10,000 worlds the Empire was
dominated by the landsraad which
consisted of many feuding noble houses
and was led by the padishah Emperor
himself 10,000 years prior to the start
of dune all thinking machines artificial
intelligence had been violently removed
from the Imperium during the but Larian
jihad such devices were forever banished
from this point on this at the time
destroyed mankind's ability to travel
safely at Lightspeed humanity moved on
in other ways however at the opening of
doom faster than life space travel is
possible due to the existence of Holzman
tribes
however for safe space travel to occur
precise predictive calculations are
required for this the guild navigators
undergo an accelerated process of
genetic mutations which misshapes them
but provides them with the ability to
predict and avoid obstacles in space
this would not be possible without the
use of spice for this reason the guild
maintains a monopoly on space travel
mélange often just called spice is the
most valued commodity in the Dune
universe it is a direct analog for oil
in the real
without spice no commerce would occur
between the thousands of worlds in the
Dune universe without spice the Empire
would fall spice also has properties
which allow it to greatly extend the
life of whoever consumes it without the
spice The Witches of the Bennett Jesuit
would lose many of their powers spice
increases longevity heightens awareness
and is also so addictive that if you
stop taking it the intense withdrawals
would mean your death there is no cure
for spice withdrawal symptoms spice is
found only on one planet in the Imperium
Arrakis also known as doom a harsh
desert planet where giant worms roam the
sands attacking all rhythmic motions
where the ancient Freeman descendants of
the Sun Sunni wander by night and still
suits which maintain the moisture of the
body in the desert water his life to
waste water would be unthinkable to a
Freeman
at the start of doom Paul Atreides and
his family moved to the planet Arrakis
they have been forced into a plot
orchestrated by the Emperor and also the
arch enemy of Paul's father Leto the
Baron Vladimir Harkonnen together the
Emperor and the harkonnens intend to
destroy the noble Atreides the original
doom novel details the awakening of
Paul's hidden abilities and his rise to
power over the next five novels Frank
Herbert teaches many things about the
trappings of power the nature and the
dangers of religious fanaticism and most
importantly the harm that can be caused
when individuals blindly follow their
leaders without question the doomed
series is an example of how an author
can completely subvert expectations but
in an interesting and clever way which
ultimately teaches us something about
the human condition with denis
villeneuve director of blade runner'
2049 and a rival currently working on
two major Hollywood productions based on
the first novel in the series there has
never been a better time to get into
dune Denis Villeneuve also seems
extremely passionate about the project
and has assembled a team of dedicated
and competent people to bring this story
to life on the big screen dune is
definitely a commitment to read so I
recommend to those of you who are
interested in getting into dune but
haven't yet to check out my ultimate
guide to doom series the first episode
is a dramatic synopsis of all six friend
Herbert books and the rest of them are
hour-long cinematic guides to each book
in the series thanks for watching make
sure you like and subscribe for more
ideas of Ice and Fire
[Music]
you